I want to continue in Volume 3, beginning at November 19, 1899. And this is the evils
of pride. First of all, I want to give you Luke 1, 51 to 52. 1 Peter 5, verses 5 to 6.
Proverbs 3, 34, and 1 John 2, 16. My adorable Jesus continues to come. And since before
he came, my mind was thinking about certain things which Jesus had told me in the past
years, and which I do not remember so well. Almost to remind me, he told me, my daughter,
pride corrodes grace. In the hearts of the proud, there is nothing but a void of all
full of smoke which produces spiritual blindness. Pride does nothing but render oneself an
idol that's called "autology" as the final insult to God. And so the proud soul does
not have her God with her. In these writings, we are told that the only safe place is to
be in our nothingness. That's where we acknowledge who we really are, and we leave the sinful
pride aside. By sin, she has tried to destroy him in her heart, and by raising an altar
within her heart, she places herself on it, and she adores herself. Unfortunately, that's
prevalent today, and I think one of the great images of that is the selfie. I adore and
glorify myself, and I will take pictures of myself in case anybody else doesn't adore
me. Well, God, she said, what an abominable monster this voice is. It seems to me that
if the soul is attentive not to let it enter into herself, she's free from all other vices
because pride is the first and the most awful of the deadly sins. But if, to her misfortune,
she let herself be dominated by it, since it is a monstrous and wicked mother, it will
deliver all of its naughty children for her, which are the other sins. O Lord, keep it
away from me, Louisa says. November the 21st, 1899, Jesus wants to delight in reflecting
himself in Louisa, who is helped by our blessed mother. This morning, as soon as Jesus came,
my beloved told me, my daughter, all your pleasure must be in reflecting yourself in
me. That is two Corinthians 3, 18. And if you do this always, you will portray all of
my qualities, my physiognomy and my very features within yourself. And I, in return, will find
all my taste and all my contentment in delighting in reflecting myself in you. Well, in two
Corinthians 3, 18, Paul says, you become like what you worship. The more you contemplate
the Lord, the more Christ like you become. The more people get into devilish stuff, the
more evil they become. You become like what you worship. So having said this, he disappeared.
Jesus disappeared. And I was meditating in my mind on the words he had just spoken to
me. All of a sudden, he came back, placing his holy hand on my head and turning my face
towards him, he said, today, I want to delight a little bit in reflecting myself in you.
So I want to give you the song of songs, chapter four, where the bridegroom delights in the
bride. Louisa says, a shiver ran down my spine, such a fright as the field I was dying because
I saw that he was staring at me, wanting to delight in my thoughts, gazes, words, and
in all the rest by reflecting himself in me, I kept repeating in my interior, God, am I
an object fit to be letting you delight or for imbitoring you? In other words, Louisa
gave the same reaction as we would do, what an earth will he see if he can see everything?
Because even we ourselves don't see everything. In the meantime, our dear queen mother came
to my help carrying a pure white garment in her hands. And all loving, she said to me,
daughter, don't fear. I myself want to make up for you. That is with her own wonderful
clothing of purity by clothing you with my innocence. That's her immaculate purity.
So that in reflecting himself in you, my son may find the greatest delight that can be
found in a human creature, Matthew five, eight, the pure and heart see God. So she clothed
me with that garment and she offered me to my dear good, Jesus telling him, accept her
out of regard from me, O dear son, and delight in her. So every fear went away from me and
Jesus delighted in me and I in him. Now isn't it wonderful to have our blessed mother coming
to our aid. Cloted with her immaculate purity. Yes, he could look. November the 24th, 1899,
Louisa wants to receive the bitterness of Jesus. This morning my sweet Jesus came and transported
me outside of myself. Now, since I saw him all full of bitterness, I prayed him and prayed
him again to pour it into me. But as much as I prayed, I could not manage to obtain that
he would pour his bitterness into me. Although as I would draw close to his mouth to receive
his bitterness, a bitter breath would come out. While I was doing this, I saw a priest
who was dying, but I couldn't recognize well who he was because I had another intention
to pray for a sick priest, but not recognizing him as the one she was supposed to pray for.
She said, I got confused whether it was him or somebody else. So I said to Jesus, Lord,
what are you doing? Don't you see the scarcity of priests there is in Colorado, then you want
to take more away from us. And Jesus not paying attention to me and threatening with these
arms said, I will destroy them more. So I want to give you Revelation 11, 18. I will
destroy the destroyers of the earth. So Jesus was using this situation, whether he was giving
her information about the particular person who was dying or not, about the crisis that's
in the clergy. So November the 26th, 1899, the delight of the Blessed Trinity because
of the sufferings of Louisa. Louisa said, as I was very much in suffering, my beloved Jesus
came and placing his arm around my neck in the act of sustaining me. Now, while close
to him, I began to do my usual adorations, which we find in the hours of the passion where
he goes through the whole person of Jesus, the adorations to all of his holy members
beginning with his most sacred head. And in the act in which I was doing this, he said
to me, my beloved, I thirst. Let me quench my thirst in your love for I cannot contain
myself anymore. And assuming the appearance of the baby, he drew himself into my arms
and began to suckle. He seemed to take immense pleasure and was all refreshed and his thirst
quenched. After this, almost wanting to play with me with a lance, funny thing to play
with a lance. With a lance he held in his hand, he pierced my heart through side to side.
I felt the most bitter pain, but all how happy I was to suffer, especially because it was
the very hands of my soul and only good who gave me the suffering. And I encouraged him
to give me greater torment. So great was the pleasure and the sweetness that I felt.
Now this being pierced by a lance in the heart is one of the experiences that people
have in the mystical life. And we know the story of the the lance of love in the life
of St. Teresa of Avila. There's even statues and pictures of her illustrating it. I want
to give you Sam 1 4 5 verse 17, which says that God can only ever act out of love because
God is love. He cannot work from anywhere else. So what Jesus is doing is not only the
best thing for Louisa, but for everybody else. That's why she says she was happy and blessed
Jesus to make me more content, tore my heart out, taking it in his hands. And with that
same lance, he opened it into two halves and found a cross shining and pure white inside.
He took it in his hands with great delight and he told me this cross was produced by
the love and the purity with which you suffer. So this is her pure motivation. She's doing
it only for love of Jesus. And this is the purity of intention that Jesus is talking
about in volume three and he will come back to it time and again. I am so delighted with
the way you suffer that I am not alone, but I call the Father and the Holy Spirit to delight
with me. So all persons of the blessed Trinity delight in her because of the way she's suffering.
And that is she's doing it voluntarily. And she's also doing it only for love of Jesus.
And she's also doing it only in love for her neighbor to try and help her neighbor. So
that's the purity that's in there and it's totally pleasing to God.
In one instant, I went about looking and I saw the three persons who are surrounding
me delighted in looking at this cross. However, lamenting to them, I said, "Great God, too
little is my suffering. I'm not content with the cross alone, but I also want the thorns
and the nails. And if I do not deserve this because I am unworthy and a sinner, certainly
you can give me the dispositions in order to deserve it." And Jesus sending me a ray
of intellectual light that's infused knowledge made me understand that he wanted me to make
the confession of my sins. In other words, if she wanted to go to this deeper level,
then he wanted to take her into a deeper purification. She said, "I felt almost floored
before the three divine persons, but the humanity of our Lord inspired me with confidence. And
so, turning to him, I recited the confit here. And then I began to make the confession of
my sins. Now, while I was all immersed in my misery, a voice came out from their midst
and said, 'We, the most blessed Trinity, forgive you, and you, you must sin no more.'"
Okay, so let's go back to Louisa being told she must confess. I want to give you one Peter
five, five to nine, where he tells us to humble ourselves before the presence and power of
God. So, sin no more, I want to give you John 5, 14, and John 8, 11. But all of a sudden
then, after the absolution, she said Jesus disappeared. After a while he came back crucified
and shared with me the pains of the cross. So, November the 27th, 1899. Grace renders
the soul happy. So, he'll come back to this subject again over and over again until he
sometimes gets it across to us. This is a VIP message. "This morning, my dear Jesus was
not coming. After many hardships, I saw him for just a little and lamenting to him because
of his delay, I said to him, 'Blessed Lord, how come you're so late? Have you perhaps
forgotten that I cannot be without you? Or that I perhaps have lost your grace and you
do not come?' But he interrupting me said, 'My daughter, do you know what my grace does?'
My grace renders the soul of the blessed happy. The souls of all the blessed and heaven happy."
And it renders the pilgrim souls, that's us, happy also. So, up to this point, I want
to give you three scriptures, 1 Peter 5, 10, Ephesians 1, 6 to 7, and Hebrews 13, 9. So,
grace renders the soul happy with this difference alone that the blessed in heaven take bliss
and delight in it, while the pilgrim souls work with it and make it circulate. In other
words, we have a job to do on the earth. So, one who possesses grace holds paradise within
herself because grace is nothing other than to possess me. In other words, Jesus is saying,
I am grace. Grace is now pouring of God. And since I alone am the enchanting object that
enchants the whole of paradise and forms all the contentment of the blessed, the soul by
possessing grace possesses her paradise wherever she is. Now, that is the testimony of Saint
Elizabeth of the Trinity. She said, 'I have heaven on earth because I have the three living
within me.' Okay. So, grace renders us happy. Why? Because grace is an outpouring of God
himself. Okay. So, November the 28th, 1899, Louisa accepts suffering in purgatory in order
to free some souls from there. So, she learns how to take on even the suffering of souls
in purgatory, which is major. And this will have repercussions in higher volumes. My beloved
Jesus came all affability. He seemed to be like an intimate friend who makes many endearments
to the other friend in order to prove his love for him. The first words he spoke to me
were, 'My beloved, if you knew how much I love you, I feel so very much drawn to loving
you. My very delays in coming force me and our new causes for my coming to fill you
with new graces and celestial carisms.' Now, why does the Lord come? He doesn't come
just to delight you in the way we do it. In other words, we're just enjoying a person's
presence. Whenever the Lord comes, he brings new levels of grace and he brings new heavenly
carisms. So, it's a major step forward each time that he comes. If only you could understand
how much I love you, you would just barely catch sight of your love compared with mine.
Our blessed mother in Mejigoria has said that if we knew how much she loved us, that we
would cry. We have no comprehension at all of how much God loves us. If we did, we wouldn't
be like the way we are. So, Louisa said, 'My sweet Jesus, what you tell me is true, but
I too feel that I love you very much. And if you say that my love compared to yours can
just barely be seen, it's because your power is without limits while mine is limited. And
therefore, I can only do according to how much you yourself give me.' That's John 15.5.
So, this is so true that when the will comes to Me to suffer more in order to prove my
love for you more, if you do not concede the pains to Me, suffering is not in My power.
And I am forced to resign myself also in this and to be the useless being which I am
by myself. I've always been. On the other hand, you have even suffering in your power
and in whatever way you want to manifest your love for Me, you can do it. My beloved, give
the power to Me and then I will show you what I can do for love of you. That's Philippians
4, 13. I can do all things in Christ who gives Me the strength. Because whatever the measure
you give to Me, that very measure I will give to you. He listened with great pleasure to
my words, all out of proportion. And almost wanting to test Me, he transported Me outside
of Myself close to a deep place full of liquid fire. And it was dark. The mere sight of its
stroke, horror and flight. Jesus said to me, here is purgatory and many souls are crammed
in this fire. Now notice crammed. The word many means millions. You will go to this place
to suffer in order to free the souls I choose. And you'll do this for love of Me. In other
words, the only motivation acceptable is that you do things for love of Jesus. Though trembling
a little immediately, Louisa said to him, everything for love of you. So notice the intention
is right and the intention is pure. I'm ready, but you must come with Me. Otherwise if you
leave Me and you do not let yourself be found anymore, and then you'll make me cry quite
a bit. So I don't want to do this without you. That's your Philippians 4, 13. He said,
but if I come with you, what would be your purgatory? Purgatory you see is the absence
of God. Now he's giving her this experience for more than one reason. One is to release
the souls that he said. But the other is that she is going to discover, but in higher volumes,
that the level of suffering that she experiences in those higher volumes is actually the same
as purgatory. And it's a very important part of her mission. If she's just getting her
first taste now. If I come with you, what would be your purgatory? That's the absence
of God. With my presence, those pains would change into joys and contentment for you.
And Louisa said, well, but I don't want to go alone. But as we go into the fire, she
said, you will remain behind my shoulders so that if I will not see you. So I will not
see you and I will accept this suffering. So she says, I want Philippians 4, 13. You've
got to be there. I can't do it. This is not possible for me. So Louisa said, I went into
that place filled with thick darkness and he followed me from behind. For fear that he
might leave me, I grabbed his hands. That's your Philippians 4, 13, holding them tightly
upon my shoulders. As I arrived down there, who can describe the pains that those souls
suffered? They are certainly unutterable for people still clothed in human flesh. We need
to know that because we're behaving wrongly at funerals. We're acting as if people are
automatically sent to heaven instead of praying for their souls. But as I entered that fire,
it would be destroyed and the darkness would be dispelled and many souls would come out
and others would be relieved. In other words, when she took the darkness and the fire, they
were released. After being there for about a quarter of an hour, we came out and Jesus
was all mournful. Immediately I said, "Tell me, my good, why are you mourning? My dear
life, have I perhaps been the cause of it because I didn't want to go into that place
of pains all by myself? Tell me, did you suffer very much in seeing those souls suffer? How
are you feeling?" So she is behaving in an absolutely human way the way we would behave.
Jesus said, "My beloved, I feel full of bitterness, so much so that I'm able to contain them
any longer. I'm about to pour them over the earth." And he said, "No, no, no, my sweet
love. You'll pour them over me, won't you? Because I'm the victim." And drawing near
my mouth, he poured a most bitter liquor in such abundance that I couldn't contain it.
And I prayed that he himself would give me the strength to bear it, otherwise that which
I had not swallowed, I myself would pour over the earth, which would be very sorrowful
for me to do. However, it seemed that he gave me the strength, though the sufferings were
so great that I felt faint. But Jesus, taking me in his arms, sustained me, telling me,
"With you, one must surrender by force." That's Matthew 11, 18. The kingdom of God suffers
violence and the violent take it by force. "You render yourself so important," he
said, "that I almost feel the necessity to content you." Now, that important thing means
you don't give up. You keep it up, you keep it up, you keep it up, you persevere. So I
want to give you the widow and the unjust judge in Luke 18, verses 1 to 8, where a woman
needed justice and the judge had no intention of giving it to her, but she absolutely refused
to give up. So in the end, he had to give her what she asked. I also want to give you
Jesus' teaching on prayer in Luke 11, verses 5 to 8, where he tells the story of the man
coming at night looking for bread, and the householder doesn't want to give them the
bread, and he says, "Look, they're all asleep, and the children are asleep. Just go away,
go away." But the man kept at it, and just in order to get rid of him, you'd give him
the bread. So the perseverance is very important. So November the 30th, 1899, sick members and
healthy members of the mystical body of Christ. Now we're talking about the church as us.
So the mystical body of Christ is 1 Corinthians 12, verses 1 to 10. Now usually when Louisa
sees Jesus all suffering, it's because of what the mystical body of Christ is doing
on the earth. It looks like, and so she learns how to be able to make reparation for it. My
adorable Jesus continues to come, and this time I saw him in the act in which he was
at the pillar, scourging at the pillar. On tying himself, Jesus threw himself into my arms
to be sympathized with by me. I plastered him to myself and began to arrange his hair,
all cluttered with blood, and to dry his eyes and face. I also kissed him and did several
acts of reparation. When I reached the hands and removed the chain, to my greatest surprise,
I saw that the head was that of our Lord, but that the members belonged to many other
people, especially religious. Now I think when she uses the word religious, she also
includes priests and hierarchy. Oh how many infected members she said, which cast more
darkness than light. On the left side were those who caused greater suffering to Jesus.
One you could see sick members, full of wormy and deep wounds, and others which were just
barely attached to that body by a nerve. So here you have members of the body of Christ
and their spiritual condition is being described in very graphic terms. Oh how that divine
head suffered and swayed over those members. On the right side then, one could see those
which were the most good, that is the healthy members shining, covered with flowers and
with celestial Jew, perfumed fragrant odors, and among these members, one could see some
which gave off an obscure perfume. Now these are the victim souls. This divine head over
these members suffered very much. Now for that I want to give you John 15, it's verses
1 to 10, "I am the vine and you are my branches." And if a branch is really dead, it's cut off.
And if a branch is doing okay, it will be pruned in order to produce more fruit.
Louisa saw that the number of the infected members in the body of Christ was greater
than the number of healthy members. Opening his most sweet mouth, Jesus told me, my daughter,
how many pains these members give me? This body you see is the mystical body of my church,
of which I glory in being the head. But how much cruel torment these members cause in
this body, Galatians 6, 17. The barks on my body are those of Christ. It seems that they
incite one another to see who will give me greater torment. And then he said, other things
about this body, which I cannot remember so well, so I'll stop here.
So December the 2nd, 1899, eloquent praise of the cross. As I was very afflicted about
certain things, which is not listed to say here, my beloved Jesus wanting to relieve
me from my affliction, came with an appearance all new. He seemed to be dressed in pale blue,
all adorned with tiny little bells of gold, which in touching one another resounded with
a sound never before heard. At the appearance of Jesus and at that gracious sound, I felt
enchanted and I and relieved in my affliction, which departed from me like smoke. I would
have remained there in silence so much that I feel the powers of my soul enchanted. Now
the powers of my soul are intellect, intellect, memory, and will, the three great powers of
the soul. I felt the powers of my soul enchanted and stoned. If blessed Jesus had not broken
my silence saying to me, my beloved daughter, all these little bells are many voices that
speak to you of my love. And they call you to love me. Now, let me see how many little
bells you have that speak to me of your love and call me to love you. And Louisa said,
oh full of blushing, I said to him, but Lord, what are you saying? I have nothing. I have
nothing but defects. And Jesus sympathizing with my misery continued, you have nothing.
It's true. Now there's your nothingness again. And the Lord keeps reminding us of it so that
we will turn to him who is all everything we are not he is. Remember John the Baptist
said that in John chapter three at the end of the chapter he said, he must increase and
I must decrease. So I go into my nothingness and he takes over. So this nothingness is
desperately important. So I've nothing but defects. And he said true. Well, then I want
to adorn you with my own little bells so that you may have many voices to call me and to
show me your love. So it seemed that he surrounded my waist with the belt adorned with these
little bells. In other words, we have to love God with his love. And we can't love him with
his love unless he gives us the love with which to love him. That's like saying a small
child wants to give his daddy a present for his birthday. But he has to go to the daddy
and say, well, you know, this week I need more money. And the daddy pretends he doesn't
know his birthday is in a few days time. And he does a kind of a mock thing and says to
the child, Oh, you're spending too much money. This is not right for your age and all the
rest of them. The child has to defend himself, you know, and say, well, some sometimes, you
know, you have greater needs than others and blah, blah, blah. Anyway, the father allows
himself to be persuaded. And he gives the money to the child. And of course, two days
later, the child comes and says happy birthday, dad, and gives the gift. But the father had
to supply the money for the child to give that gift of love to him. Now that's the way
it is between us and God. We've nothing to give to God. He has to pour out his love into
us. And we give him back his own love. He gives us all the gifts and all the virtues
and all the graces. And we respond our thing all the time is to respond to his love. So
Louisa says, after this, she remained in silence. And Jesus added, today, I take pleasure in
spending time with you. What a wonderful privilege. Tell me something. And Louisa said, you know
that all my content, contentment is being with you. And in having you, I have everything
to Corinthians 6, 10. So in possessing you, it seems I have nothing else to desire or
to say. But if he's not there, she's running around heaven and earth yelling for him. And
Jesus said, let me hear your voice that cheers my hearing. Let us converse together a little.
I have spoken to you many times about the cross today. Let me hear you speak about the
cross. Now don't forget that Louisa has no education. And the Lord is demanding that
she writes the highest mystical theology. It's just incredible. But she can't do it unless
he gives her the knowledge. So immediately he gives her infused knowledge. I felt all
confused, Louisa said, I didn't know what to say. But he sent me a ray of intellectual
light. He's able to do that for anybody. So don't be afraid to ask. He sent me a ray
of intellectual light to make him content. And I began to say, my beloved, who can say
to you what the cross is? I mean, Jesus is the one who made sense out of the cross. He's
the only one who sanctified the cross. He's the only one who gave the cross meaning before
that you wouldn't even name the cross or that you knew anybody would ever experienced it.
Who can say to you what the cross is? Your mouth alone can speak wordily of the sublimity
of the cross. But since you want me to speak, I will do it. And first of all, I want to
give you Hebrews 12, 2, and Galatians 6, 14. The cross suffered by you. Number one freed
me from slavery to the devil. Number two, it espoused me to the divinity with an indissolable
bond. Number three, the cross is fertile and gives birth to grace in me. Number four, the
cross is light. It dissolutions me of what is temporal and reveals to me what is eternal.
Number five, the cross is fire that reduces to ashes all that is not God. To the point
of emptying my heart of the tiniest blade of grass that might be in it. Number six, the
cross is a coin of inestimable value. And if I have, oh, holy spouse, the fortune of possessing
it, I will be enriched with eternal coins or eternal currency to the point of becoming
the richest in paradise because the currency that circulates in heaven is the cross suffered
on earth. Oh, some people are going to be very, very poor in heaven, aren't they? Number
seven, the cross then makes me know myself. And not only this, but it gives me the knowledge
of God. Number eight, the cross grafts all virtues into me. Number nine, the cross is
the noble pulpit of uncreated wisdom that teaches me the highest and finest and most sublime
doctrines. Number 10, so only the cross will reveal to me the most hidden mysteries, the
most secret things, the most perfect perfection. Hidden to the most erudite and learned of
the world. And there I want to give you one Corinthians one 18 to 25. Number 11, the cross
is like beneficial to water that purifies me. And not only this, but it administers to
me the nourishment of the virtues. It makes them grow. And only then does it leave me
when it brings me back to eternal life. Number 12, the cross is like celestial Jew, which
preserves and embellishes for me the beautiful lily of purity. Number 13, the cross is the
nourishment of hope. Number 14, the cross is the beacon of operating faith. Number 15,
the cross is like hard wood, which preserves the fire of charity, keeping it always lit.
Number 16, the cross is like dry wood, which dispels and puts to flight all the smoke of
pride and of vain glory, producing the humble violet of humility in the soul. Number 17,
the cross is the most powerful weapon that offends the demons and defends me from all
their claws. Therefore, the soul who possesses the cross is the envy and admiration of the
very angels and saints and the rage and indignation of the demons. Number 18, the cross is my paradise
on earth in such a way that if the paradise of the blessed up there is of delight, the
paradise down here is of sufferings. Number 19, the cross is the chain of most pure gold
that connects me to you my highest good and forms the most intimate union which can possibly
be given to the point of making my being disappear. And number 20, the cross transforms me into
you my beloved to the point that I feel lost within you and I live of your very life. That's
Galatians 2, 20 and Colossians 1, 20. Then Louisa said, "After I said this, I don't
know whether it's nonsense. My beloved Jesus was all delighted and listening to me and
taken by enthusiasm of love, kissed me all over and said to me, 'Brava, brava, my beloved
you spoke well. My love is fire.' That's Hebrews 12, 29. My love is fire but not like
the terrestrial fire which wherever it penetrates renders things sterile and reduces everything
to ashes. My fire is fertile and it renders sterile that which is not virtue. To all the
rest it gives life. It makes beautiful flowers bloom. It makes the most delicious fruits
mature and it forms the most delightful celestial garden. Now of course the fruits of the spirit
of course is Galatians 5, 20. The cross is so powerful. Now this is Jesus speaking that
I communicated so much grace to it. He said and I communicated so much grace to it as to
render it more effective than the very sacraments and this because in receiving the sacrament
of my body which is the Holy Eucharist the dispositions and free concourse of the soul
are needed in order to receive my graces and many times these are lacking. While the cross
has the virtue of disposing the soul to grace by itself. Unbelievable you need to just take
that passage go over it time and time and time again and ask the Lord to give you the
ability to take it on board and to simply accept it so that when the crosses come that
you're accepting them knowing the wonderful treasure it is. So December the 21st 1899
Louisa speaks about virginity and purity two words that our modern society wants to hear
nothing about. So I want to give you a whole lot of scriptures before I begin. Proverbs
22, 11. Two Corinthians 6, 6. Psalm 24 verse 4. Matthew 5, 8. Psalm 51 verse 10 and Revelation
22, 14. Now there's more but that'll do you for a while. After a long silence this morning
my beloved Jesus interrupted it saying to me I am the receptacle of pure souls. You
can see what's wrong with our society today if pure souls are needed to give Jesus a home
a tabernacle a receptacle. And in these words of his Louisa said I received an intellectual
light that's infused knowledge which made me understand many things about purity but
I can repeat little or nothing with words of that which I feel or that we would say that
which I grasp or understand in my intellect. However most honorable lady obedience wants
me to write something even nonsense to make her content and I will speak my nonsense about
purity. Now it's just as well the priest says to her you write because the church wants
this insight. So number one we listed everything about the cross so we list things about purity
as well. So number one it seems to me that purity is the noblest gem that the soul can
possess. That's your Matthew five eight. The soul who possesses purity is invested with
candid light one John one five in such a way that blessed God in looking at her finds his
very image. Okay that's Romans 8 29 and Genesis 2 7 he finds his very image. He feels drawn
to love her so much so that he reaches the point of becoming enamored with her. In other
words God falls in love with us and he is taken so much by love this is number two that
he gives her his most pure heart as a dwelling place. Okay so first of all we have to offer
him some kind of a dwelling place and it's only the pure and heart that see God and depending
on the level of purity that's in us will depend on how much he can come and dwell with us.
He gives her his most pure heart as a dwelling place because only that which is pure and
most clean enters into God that's Hebrews 1214. It's also the book of Revelation chapter
21 where you're told that only the saints can go into paradise and the rest are left
outside. Okay now there are other passages in scripture about that as well. Now that's
number one and number two he gives us himself as a dwelling. Number three you have to be
very clean that's utterly pure inside to enter into God. We come to the fourth one now. The
soul who possesses purity maintains within herself her original splendor which God gave
her in creating her. Isn't that absolutely incredible? Nothing is disfigured and are disennobled
in her just number four. Rather like a queen aspiring to her wedding with the celestial
king number five she preserves her nobility until this noble flower is transported into
the celestial gardens. Now I'm going to give you a whole lot of references from the song
of songs because in the song of songs Jesus identifies himself as the rose of Sharon and
the lily of the valley. So I want to give you song of songs at chapter two verses one
and two verse 16 chapter four verse five and chapter six verses two to three. Okay so this
is number six then. Oh how this virginal flower is fragrant with a distinct odor. It always
rises above all other flowers and even above the very angels how it stands out with its
varied beauty. Most people know nothing about this because they haven't yet come to this
wonderful purity. So all are taken by esteem and love and give it free step or free movement
to let it reach its divine spouse in such a way and this is number seven I think that
the first place around our Lord belongs to these noble flowers. Why he himself is the
lily of the valley. He himself is the purest of the pure so naturally those who are pure
will be closest to him and those who are impure in the real sense of sin won't get into heaven
at all. At least not unless they've been vastly purified in purgatory. And our Lord greatly
delights in strolling in the midst of these lilies that's Proverbs 8 31 which perfume
the earth and heaven. And this is number eight I think and he delights even more in being
surrounded by these lilies because he being the first noble lily and the model he is the
specimen for all the others. Now that's all the song of song stuff. And then she says
oh how beautiful it is to see a virgin soul. Now a virgin soul is one living totally and
completely forgot. Her heart gives off no other breath but that of purity and of candor.
A candor is a couple of trillion miles away from deceit or shrewdness or the duplicity
or complexity of the world. It's not even shaded by any other love which is not God.
And even her body gives off a fragrance of purity. Everything is pure in her. She's pure
in her steps. She's pure in her working. She's pure in her speaking. Pure in her looking
and pure in her moving. Everything about her. So at the mere sight of her one feels the
fragrance and recognizes a soul that is truly pure. Now worldly people might just say there's
something about that person. What carisms, what graces, what mutual love and loving
stratagems between this soul and her spouse Jesus. Now the example I would give you there
first of all is John the Apostle. He was the pure one that was so very close to Jesus and
that's why he became Jesus' favorite because he was so like him. And that's why he got
the privilege of being made the son of Mary at the foot of the cross. Because Mary too
was the purest lily on the earth and somebody who wasn't like that couldn't have been put
taking care of her. So only one who experiences these graces can say something about it. Louisa
says one cannot even narrate everything and I don't feel it's I don't feel it's my duty
to speak about this. Therefore I will keep silent and move on. Now they have to make her
talk about this again because purity is something the world has lost any value for. So we go
on in December the 22nd 1899 to talk about how God draws us to love him in three ways.
The Lord tells us in Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 that we are to love him with all our heart
and all our soul and all our being. So Louisa says he does that and drawing you in three
ways and how he manifests himself to the soul in three ways. This morning my adorable Jesus
was not coming. After much waiting and waiting he made himself just barely seen several times
like a lightning that flashes by. But I seem to see a light rather than Jesus. Now that
light is the divine will and it will be identified more and more as the divine will as we go on.
And in this light there was a voice and the first time it came it said I draw you to love
me in three ways. Now notice she sees a light and then there is a voice. You just go back
to the book of Genesis and the voice comes first and then the light let there be light
and there was light. And what you're getting is the voice or the word coming from God,
the creative word and then bringing all things into being. And so from this light one John
one five God is light. Louisa realizes that Jesus is speaking to her. Why? Because he
is the light. That's John 8 23 and John nine two to three I think it is. I am the light
of the world. If you follow me you won't be walking in darkness. So I draw you to love
me in three ways by dint of benefits, by dint of sympathy and by dint of persuasion. Now
who can say how many things I understood in these words she said. It seemed to me that
in order to attract my love and also that of other people blessed Jesus makes benefits
rain down for our good and then we call these the gifts of God the graces of God. And in
seeing that this reign of benefits does not reach the point of gaining our love. Number
two he reaches the point of rendering himself sympathetic. And what is this sympathy? It
is his pains suffered for love of us to the point of dying deluging blood upon a cross.
Where he rendered himself so sympathetic as to enamour of himself his very executioners
and his fiercest enemies. Even more. In order to attract us more and to render our love
stronger and more stable he left us the light of his most holy examples united with his
celestial doctrine which like light you see this is the light the light of his holy example
and the light of his pure doctrine. They dispel for us the darkness of this life and lead us
to eternal life. The second time the light came it said to me this is very interesting
because we're going to hear about the divine will as the light at the light and finally
in the higher volumes will be spoken about as the unity of the light because is the three
divine persons. So the second time the light came it said to me I manifest myself to the
soul in three different ways by power that represents the father by knowledge that represents
wisdom or the son and by love represents the Holy Spirit knowledge wisdom and love or sorry
power knowledge and love. The power is the father the knowledge is the word and the love
is the Holy Spirit. So here this light is the manifestation of the Blessed Trinity. Oh
how many more things I understood she said but too little is that which I am able to
manifest that's one Corinthians two nine. It seems to me that God manifests himself to
the soul by power this is the first one in the whole of creation. From the first to the
last being is the omnipotence of God manifested. The heavens the stars and all other beings
she calls them beings speak to us. This is Sam nineteen the heavens declared the glory
of God it's one to ten. So the heavens and the stars and all the others speak to us through
a mute language. They speak of a supreme being of an uncreated being of his omnipotence.
In fact the most learned person with all of his knowledge cannot arrive at creating the
most wretched mosquito. And this says that there must be a more most powerful uncreated
being who created everything and gives life and preservation to all things. Now as we go
on in these writings Jesus will say quite clearly that it is the divine will that is
the operative part of the Trinity and the divine will created everything by his word alone.
Let there be light and that the divine will remains in everything that is created in order
to preserve it in being. Oh how the whole universe in clear notes and with indelible
characters speaks to us of God and his omnipotence. That's your Sam nineteen Sam fourteen verse
one says only the fool says in his heart there's no God. Therefore one who does not see him
is voluntarily blind. Now Paul says that also in Romans chapter one you need the whole of
the chapter. So the second is what they call news or knowledge. The first one is by power
so the second one is by knowledge. It seemed to me that blessed Jesus in descending from
heaven came upon the earth in person to give us the revelation of what is invisible to us.
And in how many ways did he not manifest himself. I believe that everyone can understand the
rest by himself. Therefore I'll not go on speaking. In other words he revealed himself
totally in the scriptures and then the Holy Spirit came and was given to us as an incredible
gift. Okay she will come back to the subject because they'll make her come back. So December
the 25th 1899 this is on the day we celebrate the birth of Jesus. Jesus wants a continuous
attitude of sacrifice in the soul. So Louisa says after spending several days in almost
total privation of my highest and only good days accompanied by darkness of heart without
even being able to cry over my great loss. Though I offered to God even that loss that's
the important thing that everything we experience good, bad or indifferent we offer it with the
sufferings of Jesus if it is sufferings and if it's good stuff united with the good stuff
in Jesus and with his holy will and offer it to God for his glory and for in reparation
and substitution for sinners. I offered to God even that loss saying to him Lord except
it as a sacrifice you alone can soften this heart of mind which is so hard. Finally after
long suffering my dear queen mother came carrying the celestial baby on her lap wrapped in
a little cloth all shivering. She placed him in my arms telling me my daughter warm
him with your affections because my son was born in extreme poverty in the complete abandonment
of human beings and in the highest mortification. So many people associate Christmas day with
complete indulgence in food and everything else and here blessed mother says that it was
the exact opposite for Jesus and herself because he was born in extreme poverty complete abandonment
of human beings and in the highest mortification. Oh how pretty he was Louisa said with that
celestial beauty of his I took him in my arms and I clashed him to myself to warm him because
he was almost numb with cold since he had nothing else to cover him but one little cloth. After
I warmed him as much as I could my tender little baby moving his purple lips said do you promise
me always to be a victim soul for love of me just as I am for love of you and Louisa
said yes my little treasure I promise you and he said I'm not content with the word I want
a note now he's an infant don't forget this looking for notes and also I want an underwriting
with your blood that's quite something else isn't it. Louisa said if obedience wants it
I'll do it. In other words he's looking for a most solemn commitment from Louisa. He needs
somebody on the earth offering him sacrifice so that he can have mercy on the rest of us.
He seemed to be all content and added from the moment I was born I always kept my father
offered in sacrifice to glorify the father for the conversion of sinners and for the people who
surrounded me and who are my most faithful companions in my pains. In the same way I want your heart
to be in this continuous attitude offered in the spirit of sacrifice for these three purposes as well
to glorify the father for the conversion of sinners and to help people surrounding you.
While he was saying this the queen mother wanted the baby in order to nourish him with her most
sweet milk I gave him back to her and she uncovered her breast to place it in the mouth of the divine
baby and I clever wanting to make a joke she says it's really a play and wanted place my mouth
to suckle as well. I drew a few drops and in the acting which I was doing this day disappeared from
me and leaving me both content and discontent may everything be for the glory of God and the
confusion of this miserable sinner so she didn't let Jesus have all the milk for himself she insisted
on having some herself okay so let's stop there for this time and we will continue in the next session.